هذه ليست ماسه عاديه على الاطلاق انها
واحده من عجائب الطبيعه كما يراها
المتخصصون وزنها
11.16 قيراط اي غرامان فقط لكن عمرها
مليار سنه ويتوقع بيعها في مزاد ستقيمه
دارسوبيس للمزادات بخمسه وعشرين مليون
دولار الماسه التي تسمى لاجونا بلو تنحدر
من صنف نادر يولد حجره بعد عمليات
جيولوجيه طبيعيه تستمر لملايين السنين في
عمق بعيد داخل الارض يصل الى 150 كيلومترا
حيث يندمج عنصر البورون الكيميائي لبلورات
كريستاليه وسط حراره عاليه وضغط شديد
ويصبح الحجر ماسيا بمرور الزمن الماسه
الفريده ظهرت للجمهور خلال حفل ميدغال حيث
ارتدتها الممثله بريان كاتشوبرا ومن
المقرر ان تعرض للبيع على خاتم في مزادات
اسبوع الرفاهيه في جنيف خلال شهر مايو
[موسيقى]